I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today and we I'm
going to be doing a another one of my
fiverr gig so I'm reviewing a website
given my feedback so this one comes in
from website grandma's old [ __ ] book so
let's read this up and see what we can
find out about it so interesting so I
like I like to play on words okok book
instead of cookbook i like that i like
the website design in general looks fun
looks professional you can see it's
about your grandmother like the
background like be able to see you and
presuming this is a this is you lay
overall looks very nice hairy
professional so a good job from the
start here i looked at the homepage to
see a little bit more about the book so
she had a novel way of the scar my
chicken dinner made for nervous doctor
and read faces she feeling situation was
chicken and [ __ ] she was completely
innocent of the slang but the family's
never quite ready for the [ __ ] bomb okay
so interesting I again I like this I
like the story like to play on words
like the picture of the book I'm not
quite sure if this book is a recipe book
is it a cookbook or is it a novel you
might want to make that just a little
bit more clear for people who are coming
to the website and they're thinking
about buying this book I'd also try to
add a little more content so if you're
writing session your home page you're
trying to write for different different
keywords it helps to have it on here on
the home page and longer to give you
just give yourself chance of ranking
better looking at your title tags here
it says chicken recipes grandma and
grandma so you don't need grandma in
there twice but it sounds like it is a
book of chicken recipes so I try to put
that in here somewhere that it is a
chicken recipe cookbook maybe show a few
screenshots of it just generally add
more text to this page as well let's go
and see what else we've got here so
let's look about you about Steve so
again very short first thought you want
to add more text and show a little more
about who you are I put a picture it
looks like you have one in that video
you have from the home page
put more about you in here put it put a
nice smiling picture of you so people
can learn a little bit more about who
you are so you work works with all
things creative you right adult and
children's books will create marketing
plans were provided clients so you've
written other books if I put that in
here to you know put put links to the
adult from children books that you've
written you know show a little more
about your history why you wanted to
write this book if you're talking about
your you know you love being a friendly
to your father to your son's put a
picture of them in here the more person
you make it the more of a connection you
make with people who come to this
website and the longer they spend in the
better they feel they know you like you
trust you they're more likely to take
the next step and buy the book so I
definitely fill out that section a
little bit more what's what else let's
see about the book so there's a link on
this side on the side about the book
let's load that up the call came late
Saturday afternoon it was mom so it
looks like you're telling a story here
scroll down so it's a good food good
laws can't go wrong it looks like it's a
story about your grandmother which is
great again I'm still not sure reading
this if this is a novel or cookbook from
the home page title tag we saw that
you're you're trying to rank for chicken
recipes so I'm assuming it's a cookbook
but from this it looks like it's a story
and not a cookbook so so that confusion
may cause people not to buy because
they're not quite sure what they're
getting if it is a book of recipes you
may want to say you know included our 45
fantastic chicken recipes from your
grandma or whatever it is or has some
screenshots of it or if it's a novel
clearly say it's a novel you're telling
a great story about your grandmother so
but just make that a little bit more
clear but it's great do you have more
content on this page you should try to
aim for that on all the pages as well
not a lot of pages here so let's see the
the testimonials one what are the same
we'd love to hear from you so there's no
no testimonials yet that doesn't look
great especially the book has been
really released I would try to fill that
up boot if you get your friends and
family to leave some testimonies at the
beginning try to find if you have any
author friends who you know people may
recognize or some people were in the
cookbook who may be able to put
something on here until you get
something i'd probably take this page
down because it doesn't look good to
come the testimonials page and see
nothing but i'd still just try to get a
few testimonials and put them in and and
once you do get some testimonies i put
them on the homepage as well so when i'm
visiting this home page it's great you
have the video you've got your quick
intro you want to fill this up a little
bit more but if somebody wrote you know
best book I've ever read or best best
chicken recipes I've ever seen then that
will add a little more credibility to it
as well but overall I think the the page
is a the awesome start the layout is
really nice it looks professional it's
kind of funky and quirky fits I think
the theme of your book I just do a
little bit better job of the content
adding more in and explaining a little
bit more about what it is that you get
with the book kind of think you're well
on your way so congratulations so for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up and if
you have a comment about this website or
you have a question for your own
business feel free to leave in the
comments section below I always read
those and love seeing them come in so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode
you